-Welcome, welcome, welcome
to "The Tonight Show."
You guys, it's Veterans Day
and --
[ Cheering and applause ]
[ Rimshot ]
[ Whistling ]
Tonight, our audience is made up
of veterans and active military.
Thank you very much
for being here.
[ Cheering, whistling,
and applause ]
Welcome.
Between all of you out here
and Sylvester Stallone
backstage,
I've never felt so safe
in my entire life.
[ Laughter and applause ]
I just want to say to everyone
here and watching at home,
thank you for protecting us
from our biggest threats,
both foreign
and domestic.
[ Laughter and applause ]
You know --
[ Cheering ]
You know, I could never do what
all of you guys do.
The closest I've been
to a war zone was this morning
when I logged on to Twitter.
It was unbelievable.
[ Laughter, ohhs, and applause ]
Of course, there was
a big Veterans Day Parade
here in New York City.
[ Cheering and applause ]
You were there?
It included 25 floats,
20,000 marchers,
and one guy who was still
finishing the marathon.
[ Laughter ]
[ Southern accent ]
Alright, you can do it.
Come on, buddy, go!
[ Cheering and applause ]
Well, so many of you
in tonight's audience
earned some amazing medals
over your careers
and I think sometimes civilians
can feel a little left out,
so we decided
to make some medals
that regular people
can earn, too.
[ Laughter ]
I'll show you what I mean.
For instance,
there's a medal for...
[ Laughter, cheering,
and applause ]
You know, I don't --
Yeah, I heard you.
There's also a medal for...
It's like --
[ Laughter, cheering,
and applause ]
Next, there's a medal for....
[ Laughter, cheering,
and applause ]
Next, there's a medal for...
[ Laughter, cheering,
and applause ]
And, finally,
there's a medal for...
There you go, yeah.
[ Laughter, cheering,
and applause ]
[ Rimshot ]
I'm trying! I'm trying!
I'm trying.
I'm so honored and thrilled
that our audience is filled
with men and women who served
in uniform.
But look, I don't want to be
a stickler about this,
but when we say served
in uniform,
we're talking about people
in the military.
so, I'm sorry, sir, but you're
going to have to leave.
[ Laughter ]
-Wait, wait. No, no, hold on.
-No, no, no, I'm sorry, no.
-Wait, just a second.
This is a uniform.
-No, no.
-Come on, wait, wait, wait.
[ Cheering and applause ]
No, wait, wait, hold on.
No, no, hold on.
Oh, no!
-I appreciate it, but --
-You can't handle the truth!
-No, come on.
-I know, I know.
Get him outta here.
Sorry about that.
Let's get to some news.
Everybody's talking
about this --
in his first address
to Twitter employees,
Elon Musk said that bankruptcy
is a possibility.
Answering the question,
"What's the opposite
of a motivational speech?"
It's like --
[ Laughter ]
Twitter also suspended
the launch of Twitter Blue
because so many users
were paying to be verified,
then impersonating other people.
[ Laughter ]
Seriously, it's a mess
over there.
I knew the impersonations
were a problem
when Pope Francis slid
into my DMs.
[ Laughter and applause ]
It was weird.
And did you see this?
I read that
almost every major
cryptocurrency is crashing.
Right now, the only
Bitcoin winners are the people
who never wasted the time
to understand it.
[ Laughter, cheering,
whistling, and applause ]
[Indistinct].
It's pretty shocking.
It turns out fake money is not
as valuable as you think.
[ Laughter ]
Some news from overseas --
today President Biden was
at a climate summit in Egypt
and, during his speech,
someone interrupted him
with a loud sound.
Check this out.
-[ Echoing ]
As I stand here before you,
we've taken enormous strides
to achieve that.
-[ Howling echoes ]
-But I don't stand here alone.
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Rimshot ]
-No, you're not --
No, you're not alone.
It's you and a pack of coyotes.
[ Laughter ]
You can tell, for a second,
Biden was like,
"Please tell me you guys
are hearing this sound, too.
[ Laughter and applause ]
It's not my time yet, please.
It's not my --"
[ Laughter and applause ]
Some entertainment news --
I saw that a biopic
about Snoop Dogg's life is
in the works
and, right now,
they're trying to figure out
the best name for the movie.
For example, they're
considering names like --
-Ah, here we go.
[ Laughter ]
-What's up, Tariq?
-Let me guess.
You're going to list
a bunch of fake movie titles
about Snoop Dogg, right?
-I mean, yeah,
that was the plan.
-And then, then, like
a little graphic'll pop up,
so everyone could see the titles
and laugh along.
-Right, I want to show
our audience a good time.
-Yeah, I know exactly
how this'll go down.
See, first, a graphic'll pop up
with a picture of Snoop Dogg
that says...
-Yeah.
-And then, and then, under that,
you'll list the fake titles,
like, like...
[ Laughter and applause ]
Or, or, or...
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-I don't know.
I'm just spitballing here.
Stuff like, uh...
[ Laughter ]
And then, and then,
of course, the...
[ Laughter, cheering,
and applause ]
You know...
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-Yeah, yeah.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-What?!
-And then you'll do, you know...
[ Laughter ]
...or something like that.
-Yeah.
-Oh, and, uh...
Followed by...
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Rimshot ]
And then --
And then you'll probably end
on something topical,
like, I don't know,
instead of "John Wick,"
you'll just go with...
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-Is that how this
is going to go?
-Yeah. You nailed it.
-Cool.
It's a fun bit.
You should do it.
[ Laughter ]
-Alright. We'll do it next week.
Thank you.
I'll do it next week.
[ Cheering, whistling,
and applause ]
"Wakanda For-Reefer"?
[ Laughter ]
Hey, guys, get this --
I heard that the
National Toy Hall of Fame
just inducted the top,
Lite-Brite,
and Masters of the Universe.
Yep, they praised Lite-Brite
for introducing millions of kids
to the feeling of being burnt
by a scalding-hot lightbulb.
[ Laughter and applause ]
That's right, this year's
Toy Hall of Fame inductees
are the top, Lite-Brite,
and Masters of the Universe.
And this is very interesting --
they also announced a list
of the worst toys.
-Really?!
-Yeah.
Check out some of these.
First up, there's...
[ Laughter and applause ]
Next up, there's...
Sad.
Next, there's...
[ Laughter and ewws ]
-Ugh! Wow!
[ Rimshot ]
-I can't believe we showed that
on television.
-Oh, my God!
Pre-Dropped?
-Oh, my gosh.
-Oh, my God!
And, finally,
the worst toy of all...
[ Laughter, oohs, and applause ]
[ Cheering ]
Tickles you back. Weird.
Finally, this is exciting --
tomorrow,
the Rockefeller Center
Christmas Tree is going up.
[ Cheering and applause ]
It kicks off that special
two months in New York City
when even Navy SEALs are like,
"Let's get the hell outta here."